280 Верховна Рада так і з хвали звели
на вікторі шоку на
самочинно де пау dos осі і на і зал і
не прийшов, проте на прощання ручних
рибного риба-звір шульги свого
заступника isabel клава супер на коли
видосу колорит за рішення парламенту
поки щучин і він прокурор схопив і
заявив обирається на пенсію віктор шокін
ж 3 генерального прокурора України за
астані сир і
звір мене шкірного з них supra ось
жувала зі скандалом і то ультиматумом і
збоку заходу ви рукам для шокен залишилося
право так званих діамантових прокурорів
століття та winstone абіків вимочених
натще у нас тут naxt аналізу лижним та
на корм поганим експерти німота сп
одягається
дисет sing четвертим учням
інкарнації шоку на вигляди та вазами
зустріч ковбаси в руку в щоб за раз
план банківський змін жадібних прибуде на
лижному та на корумпованого прокурора
на донку шабуніна
можна при тому і вище на конкурс не
основі аджу тимур азії шанс ще пари
чоловіки хни найкраще кандидат червоних
навчальний тральний пронизаний дружин
садову системи
то прозора про значення говорять
європейські чиновники та kido допомагати
україна реформа вата провалів збитків
систему ми по металу загинули ще до
реформування системи прокуратури у
україну розуму новому уроці млм обожнюємо вона
багата беляші накласти зарубати їм
основні принципи і petrenko на за
особи суднових систем овик
політичного пливу за забезпечення
кислого та прозорового призначення карачик
прокурорів загалом це пилків там ще
пастор цієї системи якось правдиве
довіряю кульгати кістки експерти на валу
вшивати святого хто замінити віктора
шоку на закласти боготу проте на вигляд на
екрані як прокурор не буде дано
змінити і систему та общинної навички
прокурорський склад усіх ревнив